णमो अरिहंताणं णमो सिद्धाणं
णमो आयरियाणं णमो उवज्झायाणं णमो
लोए सव्व साहूणं नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे
मंगलं भगवान वीरो, मंगलं गौतमो गणी।
मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो, जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥
सर्वमङ्गलमाङ्गल्यं
सर्वकल्याणकारकम। प्रधानं सर्वधर्माणां
जैनं जयति शासनम॥ ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः। कामदं मोक्षदं चैव
ॐकाराय नमो नमः
श्री द्रव्यद्रव्य प्रकाश।
पंचेन ज्ञान चंचुसो वाणी
के आध्यात्मिक परकरो।
पत्र number 17। कोलकाता से
पत्र फोंघट के पुस्तक लिखा गया। खा गया।
उस जवाब में, सोनगढ़ के लिए समय उनको बुलाया है बाहर, पर फिर भी वो
सोनगढ़ जाते, नहीं थे मतलब जा नहीं सकते।
जवाब ये पत्र दिखा। स्पष्ट किया है कि मुझे,
ऐसी कोई भावना नहीं बननी
है, कि वर्तमान का पाका उड़े पलट करके
पुण्य। पाप का उड़े पलट करके पुण्य का उड़े हो और अनुकूल सहयोग मिले।
मैं ऐसी भावना रखना नहीं चाहता। आपने तो सादर प्रेम के कारण
मुझे ऐसी सलाह दी है। लेकिन मैं मानता हूँ गुरुदेव की कृपा से।
कि मेरा आत्मकल्याण तो मेरे
आत्मा से होगा। मेरे आत्मकल्याण... मेरे आत्मकल्याण अनुकूल संयोगों
से या गुरु की कृपा से नहीं हो पाए। पोता गुरु की कृपा से
है। ये आधार बुद्धि की अपेक्षा से बाहर है। आधार मुझे किसी का नहीं है।
इसीलिए,
मैं तो सिर्फ चैतन्य की भावना भावूंगा। भावना भावूंगा क्या फिर पुरुषार्थ भी करना
है। अकेली भावना भावने तो क्या। मुझे शांति
चाहिए। मुझे शांति चाहिए तो मैं आत्म आश्रित
ऐसी साधना करूँ कि राग ही खत्म हो जाए तो ही मुझे शांति मिले
मैं ऐसी भावना बना
पर सिर्फ भावना बनाता हूँ ऐसा नहीं वो भावना को
साकार करने के लिए। वो भावना को साकार होने के लिए किस प्रकार से
प्रयोग करना है वो भी उन्होंने बता दिया है।
बुद्ध के वचन का आधार लेकर के बताया है।
कि ज्ञानी को इच्छा की इच्छा नहीं है।
आत्मा के आधार के अलावा किसी और का आधार ज्ञानी को पसंद नहीं।
और अंदर में... और अंदर में सर्व प्रदेश में
मैं सिर्फ चैतन्य चैतन्य और आनंद आनंद से मुक्त वस्तु हूँ ऐसी दृष्टि एक
बार हो जाओ क्योंकि ज्ञानी ऐसा ही result क्या निकलेगा कि
शांति के लिए जो अनुकूल संयोगों
की चाहना रखते हैं वो चाह की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी
और स्वरूप दृष्टि से।
की स्वरूप
दृष्टि से automatically
सुख समुद्र का दरिया एकदम सहज उमड़ पड़ेगा।
पर के लिए विकल्प करना बेकार है, साधन जुटाना बेकार
है, उसमें इस चैतन्य का कोई लाभ नहीं है। अरे
मैं बिना किसी के भी अभी ही परिपूर्ण हूँ।
भगवान बनना है ये बात कहाँ है?
मैं तो वर्तमान में ही परमात्मा हूँ। नहीं परमात्मा एक बार ऐसी तीव्र
भावना होनी चाहिए अनुकूल संयोग मिले ऐसी भावना नहीं होनी चाहिए
मैं वर्तमान में ही परिपूर्ण परमात्मा हूँ ऐसी भावना होनी चाहिए कैसी भावना होना हो
तीव्र भावना होनी चाहिए मैं बिना किसी के ही
अभी ही परिपूर्ण हूँ
एक बार ऐसी
तीव्र भावना होनी चाहिए ताकि। ताकि सामान्य वस्तु जो
ध्रुव त्रिकाली चैतन्य परमात्मा विराजमान है उसका
ज्ञान होवे सच्ची समझ आवे ऐसा अवसर मिले।
पर में सावधानीपना नहीं। नजर बाहर नहीं। स्व में सावधानीपना होना चाहिए।
जागृति हमारा attention
ज्ञान का उपयोग सिर्फ चैतन्य मूर्ति के ऊपर होना चाहिए।
अब जब ऐसा होता है तो क्या होता है? सौगानी जी ने
अनुभव किया होगा लिखते-लिखते। कल यहाँ तक अपुन आए
थे अब आगे की बात। कि ऐसा लिखते-लिखते
सौगानी जी अंदर में दृष्टि की होगी और आनंद मिला होगा तो क्या लिखते हैं अब?
आगे की line। अरे द्रव्य सामान्य। कौन?
ये परमानंद। उसकी... उसकी महिमा करते हैं। कि अरे द्रव्य सामान्य।
एक द्रव्य अवस्था है और एक द्रव्य सामान्य। अवर्ता आवे और जावे, परिणाम आवे और जावे।
सामान्य आवे जावे नहीं। सामान्य
मतलब क्या? 3, 6, 9, 12, 15 में कौन सा
सामान्य है? 3। ऐसे
अवर्ता सुख की हो या दुख की हो।
विकल्प वाली हो या शून्यता हो। चिंता... चिंता वाली हो, बेफिक्री हो।
दुख हो या सुख हो, ये अवस्था है। बढ़ती हो, ओठ हो। ज्वार हो, बाटा हो।
धूप हो, सर्दी हो। रात हो, दिन हो।
कैसी भी, वो अवस्था है।
ये मैं नहीं, मैं common। इन सबको जानने वाला कौन? 3, 6, 9, 12, 15 में
common कौन? 12 15 में common कौन? 3। मैं
तो इन सबको जानने वाला सामान्य तत्व हूँ।
इसीलिए अपने इधर नज़र करने के बाद, आनंद लेने के बाद क्या कहते हैं?
उसकी महिमा करते हैं। हरि द्रव्य सामान्य।
द्रव्य में अवस्था आया तो अवस्था को नहीं देखते हैं, वेदन आया तो वेदन को नहीं देखा।
आनंद के ऊपर नज़र नहीं है, आनंद आया लेकिन नज़र किधर है? आनंद के ऊपर। जिसको
देखने से आनंद उमड़ पड़ा, वो चैतन्य मूर्ति, मैं स्वयं परमात्मा।
उसका आनंद क्या? द्रव्य सामान्य। अब उससे बात करते हैं अनुभव के बाद।
और ये द्रव्य सामान्य तेरे प्रताप से।
तेरा बहुत बड़ा उपकार है,
तेरी बहुत बड़ी कृपा है। तेरी मेहरबानी... तेरी मेहरबानी हुई मेरे
पर। परमात्मा प्रसन्न हुए मेरे पर।
तुमने मुझे दर्शन दिया। मैंने तुझे बहुत भटकाया अनंत काल से चौरासी के चक्कर में।
तुझे देखे बिना बहुत दुख उठाया और तुमको बहुत दुख दिया।
नरक में लेके गया, जानवर की गति में, एकेंद्री में, हर जगह बहुत भटकाया।
लेकिन फिर भी तू दया
का सागर है। कौन? वो नहीं ये। कि मैंने जब भी तेरे
को देखा तूने दरवाजा खोल दिया।
गलतियां तो माफ कर दी लेकिन आनंद का समुंदर आनंद से मुझे नहला दिया।
बोल तुझे क्या चाहिए ज्ञान, आनंद, सुख, शांति बोलो तुम बोलो मांगो क्या चाहिए।
क्या? सब कुछ दे दिया अंदर से। हमारे भूतकाल के सारे अपराधों को माफ कर दिया।
माफ़ कर दी। अब इनसे बड़ा क्षमाधारी कौन
है? अपने परमात्मा से बड़ा क्षमाधारी कौन है? यही दया का सागर हो।
तू प्यार का सागर है। नहीं वो गीत आता है। मदुरै गए थे तो एक बाई ने गाया था।
Tu प्यार का सागर है।
तेरी गुंद के प्यासे हैं। मुंद के प्यासे हैं ना। ये अंदर में
मुंद क्या है वो समुंदर है आनंद।
वो पूरा दे देगा
दरवाजा पूरा आपका ही है अंदर पूरी मालिकी आपकी है किसी के और की नहीं। ये
question। के तेरे प्रताप से तेरी मेहरबानी हुई। तेरे बड़े उपकार
तेरी क्षमा में तेरी कृपा में मैं ना रहा। तेरे प्रताप से झुकती हुई पर्या है।
भीख मांगने वाली पर्या
है ये। भीख मांगने वाली पड़ी, ये चाहिए, वो चाहिए। कहीं नहीं तो
फिर मेरा उपयोग अंदर जाना चाहिए, क्या भिखारी किया। क्या?
बाहर से कुछ नहीं मांगा तो अंदर आया तो क्या बोला?
मुझे सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए, बस trip में...
जाने से पहले अभी 2 दिन बचे हैं, 2 दिन कहाँ, 1 ही दिन।
Last है आज। Last है। Final exam अभी आज। Last exam. अगर आज शाम तक या रात भर
जाऊंगा कैसा भी करके, लेकिन दर्शन हो तो... होगा कैसा
भी करके लेकिन दर्शन हो जाए ना तो बस।
कुछ नहीं चाहिए बेड़ा पार नहीं गंगा सागर पार हो गया।
ये समुद्र में डुबकी लगा के आ रहे हैं बस। ऐसे वापस जाने में शर्म आती है।
कितनी यात्रा करेंगे हर बखत वापस
हर बखत वापस। अभी आज last 24 कलाक है
मुझे सम्यक दर्शन हो जाए ना तो अच्छा। ये मेरा उपयोग बाहर जाता क्यों है?
शर्म क्यों नहीं आती मेरे? क्या और अपने को
थप्पड़... क्या और अपने आप थप्पड़ मारता है।
अंदर में तो बहुत मारता है जी।
अपने आप बहुत दुखी होता है। कि यहाँ कर के भी ये 6-7 दिन बेकार चले।
बहुत दुखी दुखी तो बहुत होता है। कि क्या किया? भीख मंगा पनाह।
किसकी भीख मांगी? परमात्मा हो करके।
सम्यक दर्शन की भीख मांगी। कि मेरा उपयोग है ना
बाहर नहीं रहे अंदर लग जाए आत्मा में। ये पर्याय झुक गई। पर्याय झुक गए।
पर्याय झुकने में क्या खोजना पड़ता है?
मांगने में ऐसा झुकना पड़ता है। और नहीं मिलता है तो
दुखी दुखी हो जाते हैं। मांगने से दुख मिलता है। ऐसा हो जाता है। स्वयं बहुत दुखी हो
जाता है क्योंकि इच्छा की सम्यक दर्शन और वो नहीं हुआ। उपयोग
अंदर जावे ऐसी इच्छा की
और वो अंदर।
वो अंदर जावे ऐसी
इच्छा की और वो अंदर नहीं गया तो क्या होता है?
आकुल व्याकुल परेशान tension tension BP बढ़ जाता है। क्या?
मनोनी सूरत हो जाती है।
सद्गुरु के सामने मुँह दिखाने में शर्म आती है। यहाँ आकर के
भी कुछ नहीं किया। अब वहाँ को डर लगता है।
जब यहाँ आकर के कुछ नहीं किया तो वहाँ तो फिर खिलाफ मेरी मौत ही समझो।
वहाँ तो फिर business है घर में पंचायत हज़ार। फिर ऊपर से TV,
फिर telephone, फिर mobile phone।
नहीं जाना है तो भी फंस जाओगे। डर
अभी से डर लगता है तो बोलते हैं अभी ticket cancel करा के लाओ।
जाना नहीं है पूरा काम करके जाना है लेकिन नहीं वो time fix है
आगे बढ़ना नहीं है अब। पूरे पुण्य
अभी नहीं खत्म करना है थोड़ा बाकी रखना है भविष्य के लिए। क्या? तो झुकती
हुई पर्याप्त। तो झुकती हुई पर्याय है,
सम्यक दर्शन की भीख मांगने वाली पर्याय, कहीं नहीं मांगा तो यहाँ मांगो।
कि नहीं नहीं, तेरे पे नज़र जाते ही बहुत कमाल हो गया। तेरी कृपा से
ये झुकती हुई पर्याय भी सहज खड़ी हो जाती है।
क्या? Automatic भिखारी को ना चले गया। कुछ नहीं चाहिए, लाफ मारो केवल ज्ञान को ऐसा।
कितना power आया? मोक्ष, मुझे नहीं चाहिए। मोक्ष मुझे नहीं चाहिए।
किसने कहा? मैं बंधा हुआ कब था? मेरी दृष्टि बदल गई।
पहले तो मोक्ष चाहिए, जन्म मरण से मुक्त होना है। अंदर देखे तो
अंदर ना जन्म है ना मरण है। कुछ नहीं है। चार गति में से एक गति वहां
भगवान आत्मा में नहीं है कुछ।
अंदर देखे तो मैं तो मुक्त ही हूं। क्या?
सौगानी जी ने बहुत तारीफ
की उनको। कि मेरे सुन के रखा था कि मुक्ति तो बहुत मुश्किल से मिलती है। तो मुक्ति
तो बहुत मुश्किल से मिलती है बड़े-बड़े ज्ञानियों को शास्त्र पाठियों को नहीं मुक्ति
है बड़े-बड़े त्यागियों को नहीं मुक्ति। और कितने पापड़ बेलने पड़ते हैं।
मुक्ति के लिए क्या सम्यक दर्शन के लिए भी दिमाग फट जाता है।
सम्यक दर्शन भी आसानी से नहीं मिलता। ये मुक्ति शब्द को आपने इतना आसान कर दिया
सौगानी जी कहते हैं। क्या इतना easy होता होगा moksha?
मुझे आश्चर्य हो रहा है कौन बोल रहा है? कौन बोल रहे हैं?
सौगानी जी बोल रहे हैं। मुझे आश्चर्य हो रहा है। हे गुरु आपके वचनों ने जादू कर दिया।
तो ऐसा चमत्कार कर दिया है वाणी में ऐसा जादू है।
कि अब मुझे नहीं लगता मुझे मोक्ष की भी जरूरत नहीं रही अब। क्या?
मारो धन्य थयो आज अवतार रे कि मड़या मने।
नहीं चाहिए कुछ भी। तो क्या हो गया जो भीख मंगाना था मोक्ष। गया जो भीख मंगाना था
मोक्ष चाहिए। नहीं चाहिए मैं हूँ
सब मैं परिपूर्ण वर्तमान में हूँ।
केवल ज्ञान की परां मेरे पीछे पीछे धूम दबा के आएगी। क्या?
परमात्मा मुझे सामने से
बोलेगा कि नहीं तुम चलो सिद्ध स्थान। और सिद्धालय पे विराजमान हो जाओ।
नहीं आप मना करोगे तो नहीं चलेगा पहले ही सोचना था। क्या? कैम कृपादेव ऐसा कहते
हैं। कि भैया देखो 10 बार सोच लेना आप पहले।
एक बार आत्मा को देख लोगे ना, सम्यक दर्शन हो
जाएगा ना, फिर आप बोलोगे मुझे केवल ज्ञान नहीं चाहिए।
निरेक मोक्ष में नहीं जाना
है, घसीट के लेके जाऊँगा। ये सम्यक दर्शन की प्रतिज्ञा है।
एक बार आत्मा का दर्शन किया तो फिर खलास, फिर आपको जाना ही पड़ेगा मोक्ष
में। नहीं नहीं मेरे पिताजी स्वर्ग में हैं ज़रा मिल के आ जाऊँ।
मेरे पिताजी स्वर्ग में हैं ज़रा मिल के आ जाओ। मेरी मम्मी अभी जानवर गति
में है तो ज़रा मिल के आ जाओ। तो सब कुछ नहीं
है। अब चलो सीधा। नहीं सबका उद्धार करना
है कि नहीं अभी उद्धार भी नहीं करना time नहीं है। चलो ऊपर चलो।
अनंत सिद्ध भगवान तुझे बुला रहे हैं आज सिद्धों से अपनी बात हो के रहेगी आज final
है आज क्या है। Today is final day. आज
सिद्धों से अपनी बात... आज सिद्धों से अपनी बात। शुद्ध आत्मा से मुलाकात
हो के रहे। आज आज
इतना वेग हुआ दरिया किनारे अंदर की दरिया में जाना है ध्यान रखना है।
दरिया किनारे कोई जाना नहीं बिना पोशाक के। ये दरिया में जाना है देखना के।
तो कैसे देखोगे कि मैं ही परमात्मा हूँ तो क्या होगा? नजरते क्या होता है?
कि अरे प्रभु सामान्य। तेरे प्रताप से झुकती हुई पर्याय भी। काफी झुकती हुई पर्याय
भी सहज खड़ी हो जाती खड़ी करना नहीं पड़ता है।
सहज माने automatic।
खड़ी हो जाती माने मांगना भूल जाती। अब मुझे मोक्ष भी नहीं चाहिए
मुझे सम्यक दर्शन भी नहीं चाहिए। मुझे जो चाहिए था सब
मिल गया। क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ यकीन नहीं आता है।
मैं अपने को भिखारी समझता था वो नजर मिलते ही दृष्टि बदल गई।
सृष्टि बदल गई पूरी। एक second में
मोक्ष मुक्ति चाहिए सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए।
आत्मा हे भगवान तू कब दर्शन देगा? 2 घंटे से ध्यान लगा के बैठा हूँ, कमर दुख रही है।
क्या? और प्रयत्न करते करते नज़र पड़ गई तो
अब मुझे कुछ नहीं चाहिए भैया। क्या? क्या हो गया?
ये नजरिया बदल गया। मांगे वो भिखारी। मैं तो परमात्मा हूँ,
मैं काहे को मांगूँ, भीख मांगूँ, वो भी किसकी? अवस्था की। नहीं चाहिए मुझे,
जाओ। तुझे देना है तो दे,
मेरे में योग्यता है तो मुझे मुक्ति भी नहीं चाहिए। वो तो बोलेगा भैया आप ही योग्य हो
क्योंकि आप अपने को
परमात्मा मानते हो, भिखारी नहीं मानते हो। मैं भिखारियों के पास नहीं जाती। मुक्ति
की भिक्षा क्या बोलती? मैं तो कब से आपको ही ढूंढ रही थी। आई
मैं आपके पास नहीं। आई मैं आपके पास में लेकिन आप सम्यक दर्शन कब होगा ऐसा
देख रहे थे तो मैं वापस चली गई।
क्या?
आपको वरमाला लेके आई थी मुक्ति सुंदरी,
फूलों की माला लेकर के आनंद की, आनंद के फूलों की माला लेकर के
आप ध्यान में बैठे थे।
और मैं आई मुक्ति माला लेकर के आनंद की। लेकिन मैंने देखा कि
आप सम्यक दर्शन कब होगा,
कब
होगा,
कब होगा। आप परमात्मा का ध्यान नहीं कर रहे थे।
परमात्मा का ध्यान नहीं करते थे। आप किसका ध्यान करते थे? अवस्था। और
फिर? अभिवेदना आएगा। अभी तक आया नहीं। अभी आया। इसका ध्यान करते थे।
तो फिर मैं आई से कि मैं दूर से चले
गया। कि आपको नहीं है परमात्मा का ध्यान नहीं करते उनको
क्या देना है? भिखारी को क्या ध्यान?
माला बेन का। मुझे तो परमात्मा चाहिए था। पलटी और मैं एक दफे और नजर
करूं क्या होता है। बाद में ऐसे पलट के देखी
तो आप परमात्मा का ध्यान कर रहे हो। नहीं चाहिए मुझे वेदन। नहीं चाहिए मुझे
समय के साथ। तो मैं दौड़ते दौड़ते आई और आपके गले में माला...
मुझे तो परमात्मा चाहिए था।
देखो। किसको होता है मुक्ति किसको मिलती
है। और मैं... और मैं पहना है तो आप
मना करने के लिए भी
उपयोग बाहर नहीं आया आपका मुझे नहीं चाहिए नहीं चाहिए। ये तो बाद में बोला कि मुझे
माला भी नहीं चाहिए। अब मुझे माला का क्या प्रयोजन है?
वो तो बाद में उस time में तो आपने कुछ नहीं। मेरे सामने
देखा भी नहीं था मुझे ऐसा ही परमात्मा चाहिए। कि जो अपने पैरों पे खड़ा है।
उससे मैं शादी करूंगी।
शादी किससे करूंगी? कादी किससे करूंगी? वो मैं उसके गले पड़ूँ,
वो किसी और के गले पड़ा हो, तो नहीं मेरे को नहीं चाहिए ऐसा परमात्मा।
क्या?
पति परम कृपालु महाराज। अविनाशी। अविनाशी सुख देना। मेरे को तो ऐसा
परमात्मा चाहिए। मैं ऐसे नौकरी करता हूँ, भीख माँगता हूँ खुद ही।
उसके घर... मैं तो पहले पूछती थी washing machine है आपके
पास? kitchen में काम वाले servant है? Kitchen में काम वाले servant है। अलग से
bedroom है, TV color TV है। AC है
room में AC। क्या? Maruti
car है। तुम्हें
आती नहीं। अच्छा
अभी आजकल वो सब...
वो लड़का लड़की देखने जाता है, लड़की लड़के को
बराबर देख लेती है
अच्छी तरह से। कि तुम कितने पानी में हो। क्या? लड़की क्या लड़का
क्या देखेगा लड़की को? अब उल्टा
है कौन है उल्टा। उल्टा से कौन सा उल्टा
है। अब इतनी पढ़ी लिखी रहती है लड़की कि
उसकी पूरी अजामत कर लेती है। First meeting में ही पूरा पानी उतार देती है।
बोलो क्या है ये सब
है? यहाँ पे ये बात है। कि उसको परमात्मा चाहिए, भीख मंगा भिखारी नहीं चाहिए।
तो यहाँ सौगानी जी ने क्या लिखा है? हरे द्रव्य सामान्य,
तेरे प्रताप से झुकती हुई परे भी सहज खड़ी हो जाती। पर्याय भी सहज खड़ी हो जाती है।
भीख मांगने वाली पर्या है।
उसमें भिखारीपना चले आता है और उसको खड़ा नहीं रखना पड़ता है,
वो अपने आप खड़ी हो जाती है। अनादि का बोझा प्रतिक्षण हटा जाता है।
कितना बोझा था, ये करूँ, वो करूँ, क्या करूँ, सुखी होने के लिए मैं क्या करूँ, कितने
file कितनी बना के रखी थी,
ये करना है, वो करना है, वैसा करना है, ये
नहीं करना है, ये... ये नहीं करना है। ये, ये करूंगा तो दुखी हो जाऊंगा,
ये नहीं करूंगा तो दुखी हो जाऊंगा। करूं नहीं करूं कि कितनी बड़ी file थी,
कितना बोझा था?
आपके दर्शन हुए तो अनादि का जो बोझा था वो तकसा... तका।
बोझा ही गया। क्या करना है? करना क्या हो? करना करना रहा क्या?
तो जो हो रहा है film,
देखो जान, और क्या। करता तो भाव ही गया। एक भी... एक भी परिणाम को
आगे पीछे नहीं करना है। एक भी रजकण को आगे पीछे नहीं करना
है। कर सकता नहीं।
सूके घास के किनके के दो टुकड़े करने की ताकत मेरे में...
परमात्मा को देखने के बाद करने को क्या बचा?
कुछ नहीं बचा। अनंत का बोझा प्रतिक्षण
हर हर moment हटा जाता है। हटता जाता है पूर्वों की file के कारण
करूँ नहीं करूँ ऐसा होने जाते हैं। लेकिन हर वक्त इसके प्रताप से क्या होता
है? बोझा नहीं, प्रत्येक क्षण बोझा हटते जाता है। देखो।
और क्या होता है? बोझा कम होते जाता है हर पल। और और क्या होता है?
तेरे प्रताप से क्या होता है और? उत्तरांतर, day by day, पल by पल। सु... पल
सुख की वृद्धि होनी होती जाती है।
देखो जानने देखने से जो सुख मिलता है वो सुख की वृद्धि day by day पल बाय पल
वृद्धि होती जाती है। बोझा कम होते जाता है। और आनंद की वृद्धि
होती रहती है। धन्य है तेरा बोध।
मैं तेरे को भूल करके अपने आप को भूल करके हैरान हो गया था।
जे स्वरूप समझा बिना, पाम्यो दुख अनंत। एक एक ही गलती की थी।
मैं अपने तेरे को भूल गया था।
लेकिन तेरे पे नज़र पड़ते ही, तेरा स्वरूप ख्याल में आते ही, क्या हो गया?
ये सब फायदा हो गया। कठ तो भाव zero खत्म हो गया। अशांति
day by day कम होते जा रही है। सुख की वृद्धि day by day बढ़ती जा रही
है। भिखारीपना जो था ना अवस्था में... भिखारीपना
जो था ना अवस्था में वो छूट गया और परमात्मा पद
ताकत आ गई। पैरों में जान आ गई। जिंदगी जीने का एक मकसद मिला मेरे।
धन्य है तेरा कोख। वाह।
दृष्टि पड़ते ही समझ आते ही पूरा change हो गया।
वो गिनती करता था ना 10 पुलिस में। तो 10 मूर्खे जो
थे गांव के लोग। मूर्खे जो थे गाँव के लोग। एक गाँव से दूसरे गाँव जाए बीच में तालाब
नदी आई पैर के गए सामने। फिर बोले हम 10 जने थे
check कर लें कि 10 जने हैं कि नहीं। तो उन्होंने check किया सब लोग line में खड़े रहो
मैं गिनती करता हूँ। अपने को गिनती नहीं किए।
कितने थे? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9। अरे भाई ये
कहाँ गया? 10 थे। तुझे बराबर... तुझे बराबर
गिनती करना नहीं आता तुम line में खड़े रहो मैं गिनता हूँ।
क्या किया उसने भी वही धंधा किया। अरे सही है तुम बोलता ऐसे ही है ना वो भी
है। वो भी इसके उसका कोई भाई था ना मूर्ख ही था।
तुम दोनों मूर्ख के सरदार हो गिनती करना नहीं आता है।
चलो line में खड़े रहो मैं बोलता हूँ। तीसरा है तीसरे में
भी वही। हमारे आजू-बाजू जितने भी लोग हैं सब ऐसे ही हैं।
जहाँ रहते हैं, कोई अपने को जानता नहीं। सब मूरख के सरदार हैं।
और इसमें से अगर एक सुलझा हुआ आदमी गया तो
उसके तो बड़ा मखौल ही कर देते हैं एक बार, जीने नहीं देते हैं।
क्या? तो उनके बीच में कैसे रहना? अज्ञानी बन करके
रहना। भले ही ज्ञान हो गया हो लेकिन बताना नहीं कि मुझे ज्ञान हो
गया है। क्योंकि नहीं तो... क्योंकि नहीं तो हकाल देंगे कि हम मूर्खों के
साथ में एक अच्छा आदमी कैसे आए।
सब पागलों के बीच में। उसको भी पागल कर दो। हमरे साथ के नहीं हो get out ऐसा बोलेंगे।
इसीलिए अगर आत्मज्ञान हो जाए ना।
तो मेहरबानी करके आज क्योंकि आज final है ना final हो जाएगा। बताना नहीं किसी
को। कि मुझे आत्मज्ञान हो गया पागल बन करके
रहने दो। नहीं तो धुलाई कर देंगे कि तेरे को हो गया
मेरे को नहीं हुआ तो मेरे को आके। हो गया मेरे को नहीं हुआ तो मेरे को आप उनको
जादू करते हो और मेरे को
पक्षपात करते हो मैं इतनी कल से भक्ति नहीं करूँगा।
इतने पक्षपात थी। उसको तो दे दिया मेरे से
पीछे थी पीछे आए थे जल्दी हो गया। और मेरे अटक गई। तो
मेरे भी गालियां हो जाएंगी इसलिए
किसी को बताना नहीं कम से
कम मेरी गाल रखना। बोलना नहीं किसी को अगर हो
गया। क्या बोलते हैं?
धन्य है तेरा बोध। ओ तेन दुखों में सबने ऐसा किया,
गलती क्या हो गई थी? 10 थे के 9 थे? 10 ही
थे, गलती क्या हुई थी?
अपने को भुलाया था। और अगर फिर मालूम पड़ गया कि मैं तो इधर ही हूँ, यहाँ से गिनना है,
हम 10 के 10 हैं और बोध हुआ तो क्या हुआ? रो
रहे थे ना जो, एक हो गया, क्या... थे ना जो एक खो गया
क्या मुँह दिखाएंगे गाँव में जाकर के।
क्या? बिचारा कितना अच्छा था लेकिन कौन? क्या?
कितने हो गए डूब गया सो लेकिन नाम क्या?
नाम कहाँ से डूब गया? सब यहाँ हाजिर हैं। कानजी, हरजी सब यहाँ थे।
किसका? तो वो बिचारा डूब गया। और रोने लगे।
क्या आदमी मर जाते हैं। रोते हैं। कान, कान बोलते हैं मोका। कान कान बोलते हैं मो कान।
तो सब बोले थे ना तो आया एक आदमी कि भैया
आप 10 के 10 कैसे रो रहे हो? 10 कहाँ हैं एक तो दुख गया
है। तो उसने देखा। तो
है तो 10 रो रहे हैं क्या हुआ है बोले बात तो क्या है हमारे में हम 10 जने थे।
ऐसा है ना एक दुख गया है। उसको समझ में आ गया। इन सबका सुख दुख
मिला है। उसको समझ में आ
गया एक। उसको समझ में आ गया
ना कि ये काम करो। सब line में खड़े हो जाओ
मैं गिनती करता हूँ बस। अभी ढूंढ के निकालता हूँ। ढूंढेगा कहाँ था? कहाँ वो आज ही था?
ढूंढना कर तो पा रहा था वो। पे करके रो रहे थे। पे कौन मर गया अगर नाम तो बोलो।
किसका नाम बोलेंगे?
ये देखो मैं तपली मारता हूँ नीचे बैठ जाओ। जिसको तपली मारता हूँ। और जोर से बोलना ये।
दो तपले मरते गए। कितने हैं दस मिल गया मिल गया कुछ। इतने दर्द मिल गया मिल
गया खुशी। क्या मिला क्या था?
पढ़ाई कहाँ था? इतनी बात है। इसलिए कहते हैं धन्य है तेरा।
तो इतनी बात। मैं मौजूद हूँ। प्रदेशे प्रदेशे।
मैं मात्र चेतन चेतन
और आनंद आनंद से ओतप्रोत वस्तु हूँ। Finish.
आज 24 घंटे में इतना काम करे तो
परमात्मा मिल जाएगा। क्या? क्या करना है? Lesson homework।
अभी डायरी पर पढ़ना नहीं है, मेरे को भी मेरा homework करना है। Lesson करने के
बाद ही बात करना,
बात नहीं करना मेरे साथ।
डायरी नहीं पढ़ने वाला अब। इतना homework
करके आना मेरे को।
हाँ? Sentence। Sentence repeat करो। Homework। आज का
final exam। क्या? जाओ। क्या? मैं कौन हूँ? प्रदेश प्रदेश में
मैं मात्र चेतन चेतन
व आनंद आनंद की ओतप्रोत वस्तु हूँ।
बस। इतना काम करना है। खोजना नहीं है।
खोजने को नहीं बोला है मैं हूँ। मैं। मैं।
दुनिया के मगरमच्छ भी। सिर्फ देख लेना है, आज्ञाकारी को देखना है। आज्ञाकारी को।
मेरे पास तो कोई नहीं आ रहा पूछने के लिए,
homework करने के बाद पूछना है तो वो ऐसे लोग।
उसका सर खा लेना है, मेरा सर नहीं खाना है। नहीं तो सौगानी जी के पास भेज दूंगा।
सदाशिव जी कहाँ गए हैं मालूम? धन्य
है तेरा बोध। अब गुरुदेव कार्यकरण
देखो इस बात को गुरुदेव कार्यकरण और दोबारा करते हैं। गुरुदेव के वचन को।
इन्होंने इधर repeat किया।
ज्ञानी ने ज्या स्वरूप निदान प्रगट्यो। क्या?
ज्ञान दर्शाने में मतलब पहले अज्ञान दशा थी
अंतर्दृष्टि परमात्मा को देखा वो ज्ञानी बन गया। पांतर।
अब ज्ञानी बन गए। पर अंदर के निदान जो थे,
सुख, शांति, आनंद जो
भी, सब बाहर आए। भिखारी में से करोड़पति
नहीं बना, कितना परमात्मा बन गया।
पहले भिखारी था, अब क्या हो गया?
कितनी lottery लगी? ₹1,00,00,000 की, ₹10,00,00,000 की, कितनी lottery लगी?
अनमोल। परमात्मा। अरे final।
अब इससे ज्यादा lottery क्या चाहिए बोलो? क्या lottery किने के
सबको दी? ये lottery की ticket सबको दी गई है। कौन सी ticket है ये lottery की?
कौन सी ticket बोला हमने? sentence एक बोला था। हाँ।
प्रदेश से प्रदेश से। मैं मात्र
चेतन चेतन एवं आनंद आनंद से बोध बोध वस्तु हूँ। ये lottery की ticket सबको दी गई
है। अब number किसका लगता है देखना
है। अगर number... आंखना आगळ number लग गया तो करोड नहीं मळे.
दस करोड नहीं मळे, अबजो नहीं मळे, क्यां मळशे? स्वर्ग.
स्वर्गलोक, पाताळलोक, मध्यलोक नहीं मळे,
एथी पण ऊंचो कोण छे? परमात्मा. परमात्मा, ए मळी
जाय. अने आनंद आनंद थई जाय. तो अहींया गुरुदेव ए कहे छे,
ज्ञानीने ज्यां स्वरूप निदान प्रगट थयुं, त्यां पर्यायमां... क्या पर्याय
में पर्याय में ज्ञानी ने जहां स्वरूप निदान
प्रकट किया वहां बहुत बड़ा change आया पर्याय में द्रव्य में change
होने का कोई सवाल नहीं
है परमात्मा तो
जैसा पहले था
वैसा है जब अपने स्वरूप को नहीं। जब अपने स्वरूप
को नहीं जानता था
तब भी वो परमात्मा था। अब
जानता है तब भी परमात्मा है
और आगे जाकर के परमात्मा बन जाएगा।
शिधालय में जाएगा तब भी। उसमें तो कोई change नहीं हुई। फिर change किसमें आया?
केम अवर्ता में आया। तो ज्ञानी को जब स्वरूप की दृष्टि हुई और अंदर की शांति बाहर आई।
तो क्या हुआ? त्यहाँ परे में जुवानी आवी जाए छे। क्या?
कल dance कर रहे थे? क्या हुआ था ये? ये क्या हुआ?
जुवानी आ जाती है। किसमें आया? पर्याय में।
परमात्मा को देखा तो
पर्याय में जुवानी आ जाती है। Dance करने लग जाते हैं। ये
बच्चे दौड़ नहीं पाते हैं और बुड्ढे दौड़ना जानते हैं लेकिन दौड़ नहीं सकते हैं।
भाग नहीं सकते। ये ताकत किसमें है अकेले?
जुबानी में। सब भागने लग जाता
है। नाचने लग जाता है।
पैरों में जोर आ जाते हैं। नाचने लग
जाता है। आनंद विभोर हो
जाता है। पर एमा जुबानी आ गई है। जीवन कभी बीत नहीं मालूम मैं। अगर हटा
कट्टा सब प्रकार से बराबर और कोई
भी young लड़का। Please 5 रुपये। Please ₹5 दो
हम तो क्या बोलेंगे उसको? गरीब आदमी हो, बूढ़ा आदमी हो,
तेल बराबर नहीं चलता है, हाथ में लकड़ी हो, पैर में coat हो, कुछ हो, अंधा हो, या
या औरत कोई हो, उसके हाथ में छोटा बच्चा हो,
पहनने के लिए wearless बराबर हो, दया आती है। या कोई कोई जुवान आदमी हो,
वो मांगे तो क्या होता है? दया आती है कि गुस्सा आता है?
गुस्सा आता है। अभी हाथ पैर बराबर है, काम कर सकता है।
कम से कम coolie बन सकता है
station के ऊपर। ये
मांगता क्यों? ₹1 भी नहीं मिलेगा उसको। इसी प्रकार से
जुआनी आ जाती है मतलब क्या होता है?
उसका मांगना मिट जाता है। अपना पड़ोस बल जागृत होता है।
अपने पैर पे खड़ा हो जाता है।
खुद मेहनत करता है, मैं किसी का नहीं, मैं खुद मेहनत करूंगा, मैं खुद ही पालूंगा।
किसी के सहारे की जवान आदमी को जरूरत,
बच्चों को जरूरत है, बुड्ढों को जरूरत है, लेकिन जवान आदमी को
किसी के सहारे की जरूरत नहीं है।
तो ज्ञानी को जब स्वरूप का निदान प्रकट हुआ तब पर्याय में जुवानी आ ही जाए से।
ये क्या हो जाए से?
निर्भयता आ जाए से, डर निकल जाता है कि अब मेरा क्या होगा। सब निकल जाता है कि
अब मेरा क्या होगा? क्या? आत्मा
का दर्शन होने के बाद मेरा क्या होगा?
खत्म। द खत्म हमेशा के लिए। दूसरा क्या होता है?
निशंत्ता आ जाती है। शंका नहीं होती है।
कि मैं परमात्मा होऊंगा कि नहीं होऊंगा कुछ दूसरा कुछ तो
अनुभव नहीं हुआ ना? क्या यही सम्यक दर्शन था?
इतना ही बस?
क्या अपने पे doubt आ जाता है। अपने पे doubt आया था। नहीं तो मुझे
पहले से मालूम था कि मैं
भगवान आत्मा शरीर से भिन्न हूँ। अब देखा तो भी क्या,
केन थोड़ा देखा, अलग थोड़ा देखा?
क्या? पहले मालूम था वही, वही मालूम हुआ।
फरक क्या हुआ? कि पहले जानते थे सिर्फ, अभी जानते हो और साथ में
मानते हो, ये फर्क आया बहुत बड़ा। लेकिन difference ज्यादा नहीं लगता है।
क्योंकि जैसा जाना था पहले बुद्धि में... था पहले बुद्धि में। ऐसा ही मानना
हुआ। तो वो तो पहले से था, फर्क क्या हुआ? क्या इतना ही बस?
मान्यता में तो बहुत बड़ा change हुआ। कभी-कभी दांव उठा जाता है।
कि इतनी बात बस? रामब्रह्म में बदल गया। हाँ? रामब्रह्म में बदल गया। वो ज्ञान
की निर्मलता नहीं होने के कारण, अनुभव तो हुआ।
लेकिन ज्ञान की निर्मलता नहीं होने के कारण, वो दूसरे symptoms जो
हैं... वो दूसरे symptoms जो है ना, उसको पकड़ने में उसके आधार से निर्णय
करना होता है। बाकी उसको
आश्चर्य होता है, आश्चर्य क्या उसको लगता है कि इतना पाया क्या है।
ऐसे बहुत कुछ पाया है लेकिन यही सम्यक दर्शन है, down हो जाता है।
लेकिन जब ज्ञानी को स्वरूप निदान प्रकट होता है तब,
पर्याय में जीवानी है कि विकमगापना निकल जाता
है। सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए ध्यान करना है वो बात नहीं रहती देखो।
पर्याय में जीवानी... पहले में जुआनी आई मतलब क्या?
और मैं ध्यान करूँ खत्म। आना है तो आएगा ध्यान करना, मैं नहीं पीछे हटूँगा। क्या?
जुआनी आ जाती है मतलब क्या?
जैसे young आदमी को किसी की परवाह नहीं। क्या मांगतन ऐसे
ज्ञानी कभी भी अपने स्वरूप का ध्यान करने को सामने से बैठते नहीं।
कर्तव्य भाव से। क्या?
कि important... ये important change है। Second third में क्या फर्क है?
कि second के बाद तो mesmerism हो जाता है कि यही चाहिए बार-बार देखो बार-बार देखो।
पर देख लिया। पर अब ये जुआ नहीं आया कि अब ध्यान करना
है। कि इच्छा ही नहीं हो रही है ध्यान में बैठने की।
ध्यान में बैठने की इच्छा नहीं हुआ। देखो time क्यों waste कर रहे
हो? वो time waste करता हूँ मालूम है उसको।
अंदर देखूंगा शांति मिलेगी मालूम है उसको
लेकिन... शांति मिलेगी मालूम है उसको लेकिन फिर भी चाहते हुए भी बैठने
का नहीं हुआ है। ये क्या
है? वो पढ़ाई में जुबानी आ गई। और डर नहीं लगता है कि मेरा क्या
होगा। पहले डर लगता था कि
गिरेगा कि नहीं गिरेगा अभी second stage है।
Third stage तो अभी तक हुआ नहीं। डर लगता था। कहीं ऐसा ना हो कि वापस चले जाओ।
क्या? फिर यहाँ से गिर जाओ। डर लगता
था। अभी निशंका आ गई। निशंकता आ गई। क्या निडरता आ गई। और निशंकता माने क्या?
कैसी निशंकता होती है मानो? आत्मा का अनुभव
में। कि तीर्थंकर भगवान आकर के उसको बोले कि ऐसा थोड़ा आत्मा का अनुभव होता है।
अनुभव में तो ऐसा होता है ना वैसा होता है ना, तेरे सफेद बाल काले हो जाते हैं। क्या?
और बुड्ढा जो यहाँ कड़तनी पड़ी है ना साहब, अच्छा रुपआड़ा हो जाता है।
और शरीर में... और शरीर में रोग है ना कमर दुखती है ना ये सब।
आत्मा का अनुभव होता है तो कुछ रोग बोक सब मिट जाते
हैं। तुझे कहाँ ऐसा हुआ है? जा तुझे आत्मज्ञान नहीं हुआ है तो क्या बोलेगा?
काहे को परीक्षा लेते हो? मुझे मालूम है तो तुझे मालूम है। क्या?
परमात्मा को बोल देगा जो तने मालूम है कि मने खबर है। क्या?
वो मानेगा नहीं। वो तो शंका, शंका नहीं रहती अपने आप में। शंका नहीं रहती अपने
आप को। कोई भी कुछ भी बोले, मुझे मालूम है मैंने इसका स्वाद चखा है।
मुझे आनंद की अनुभूति हुई है। मुझे पक्का विश्वास है कि
आप मेरी परीक्षा ले रहे हो। मैं आपकी जाल में फंसने वाला, ये निस्संक है।
कोई कुछ भी बोले। मुझे हुआ है, मेरा भले मुझे propaganda नहीं करना है।
मुझे मान सम्मान नहीं चाहिए। लेकिन मुझे पता है कि मैं कहां खड़ा हूं। ऐसे... ऐसे
गुरुदेव के वचन है कि
ज्ञानी ने जहाँ स्वरूप निदान प्रकट किया, वहाँ पर्याय में जुवानी आ जाती है, निर्भयता
आ जाती है, निशंकता आ जाती है। आपकी sir पहले वाली बात में तो इतना confident
रहता है कि उसने पूरी आखरी बात कह दी। अब ये
दोनों में चीज़ आत्मपरक
आत्मा के साथ दोनों में same है। फिर ये
confidence उसको
आत्मा को
देखने के बाद... Yes. तो अनुभव आ तो... तो अनुभव
आता है। immediate आता है। नहीं immediate, ये तो immediate आता
है। immediate आता है तभी तो ये बात। और
एक तो ये confidence, दूसरी बात मैंने बताई निर्भयता की बात। दर्द दर्द जो
मेरा क्या होगा अनुभव नहीं होगा तो क्या होगा?
time चले जा रहा है,
जल्दी जल्दी करूँ ऐसा दर्द जो लगता है ना वो नहीं रहता हूँ। तीसरा एक बात बताइए।
पर्याय में जुबानें आ जाती हैं।
जुबान कभी मांगता नहीं इस प्रकार से।
जीभन कभी मांगता नहीं, इस
प्रकार से ये भी ध्यान ध्यान करना है, आत्मा प्रदर्शन करना है.
तो वात नहीं रहेती. ध्यान करने को बेठता नहीं, ध्यान हो जाता है वो अलग बात है. ये
जात चला करके
कर्तव्य भाव
से ध्यान करने जाता...
ए एक important बात
है. 3 point है. ज्ञानी के 3 point यहां बताये. थड संकेत हो गया तो क्या होता है? ये
होता है. ज्ञानीने ज्या स्वरूप निदान प्राप्त्युं,
त्यां पर्यायमां... ज्ञान प्रगट्युं त्यां पर्यायमां जुवानी आवी जाय छे. निर्भयता
आवी जाय छे, डर
नीकळी जाता है और तीसरा
निशंका आ जाती है. शंका नहीं रहेती अपने आपको.
अंश में देखानी छे. देखातुं क्यां हो? तो
ज्ञान होय. माने कोण? ज्ञान अने मानमां फरक छे. मानने में
फर्क है। जाने और मानने में कितना फर्क है? माना
भी तो अंश में तो अंत हुआ
ही है, वो मान्यता तो है ही।
तो फिर मैं
काहे को दुखी होते हो, सर पे पतरा क्यों मारते हो?
लेकिन माना नहीं है इसलिए सर पे पतरा मारता है। अभी भी कुछ चाहिए।
अगर परमात्मा को देखा है,
फिर परमात्मा मानता है तो ध्यान करूँ ध्यान करूँ काहे को करता है?
इसका मतलब क्या, माना नहीं। जाना है, माना नहीं। Second में third में एक फर्क। सदा।
सहज ध्यान का ध्यान। second stage के अंदर ये ज्ञानी है कि अज्ञानी है?
अज्ञानी है। क्यों? श्रद्धा बदली नहीं है। माना नहीं है। जाना है? माना नहीं है।
third में क्या होता है? जैसा second में जाना वैसा ही third में जानना होता है।
लेकिन साथ में क्या add हुआ है? माना है। सहज
ध्यान। आया समझ में? सहज ध्यान।
difference क्या है? और उसके बाद और 3 point बताया। जुगोनी आवे जा। 3 point
बताव्या. जीवनी आवी जाय छे. निर्भयता
आवी जाय छे अने निशंकता आवी जाय
छे. सरस. ए important छे. ओर वागे क्यां होता है?
आत्मप्रदर्शन होता है त्यारे. क्षणे क्षणे अबंध स्वरूप प्रगट थतुं जाय छे.
एकदम प्रगट नहीं होता है. एकदम प्रगट नहीं होता ने?
श्रद्धा में तो पूरा देख लिया है के में परमात्मा हुं. पछी क्षणे क्षणे
अबंध स्वरूप प्रगट थतुं जाय छे. अभंग स्वरूप
प्रकट थतुजा चाहिए किसमें? Clarity के अंदर। ज्ञान में निर्मलता
में। कि अनुभव तो हो गया।
ये सब सारे गुण प्रकट हो गए लेकिन ऐसे हुआ है
ऐसा ज्ञान ने बराबर जाना नहीं। अब क्या होता है?
development। किसका development? श्रद्धा तो saint person हो गई।
लेकिन ज्ञान saint person नहीं था। इसलिए क्या होता है? धीरे धीरे धीरे प्रतिपल
उसका... उसका श्रद्धा का परिणमन चालू हो जाता है। वो श्रद्धा क्या करती है?
श्रद्धा और ज्ञान का निमित्त नैमित्तिक संबंध है। श्रद्धा होने के बाद
ज्ञान अधूरा है तो सबसे पहले वो अपने लबन की clarity हो जाती
है। केवल ज्ञान तो बाद में होगा। केवल ज्ञान में तो सारी दुनिया दिखेगी।
लेकिन शुरुआत कहाँ से करेगा ज्ञान की निर्मलता का? अपने समान।
तो यहाँ से शुरू करेगा वो जो श्रद्धा... तो यहाँ से शुरू करेगा जो
श्रद्धा हुई है ना, वो श्रद्धा के वश
से ज्ञान अंतर्मुखी हो करके अपनी जो अंदर की जो उलझनें हैं, जो ज्ञान की
कमी के कारण है, या निर्मलता
नहीं है इसके कारण। वो अंदर में जो उलझन होती है कि मैं कहाँ खड़ा हूँ, मैं किधर हूँ,
मेरी स्थिति क्या है,
ऐसी वो श्रद्धा की परिणति के कारण बार-बार बार-बार वहाँ ध्यान जाते-जाते क्या होता है,
उपयोग वहाँ जाते-जाते क्या होता है, ज्ञान
धीरे-धीरे निर्मल होता है। ज्ञान धीरे-धीरे धूमन होता है। तो क्षणे-क्षणे
अभंग स्वरूप, परमात्मा स्वरूप
ज्ञान में
उसकी छवि बैठ जाती है, बैठती जाती है। आगे जो
धूल लगी है ना, वो निकल जाती है। सहज ध्यान कैसे
हो जाता है? सहज ध्यान... सहज ध्यान कैसे
हो जाता
है? automatic ध्यान हो जाता है। अलग से बैठा नहीं था लेकिन अपने आप ध्यान चले गया
था। उपयोग बाहर था।
उसने कोई ऐसा मन में भी नहीं सोचा था कि
मेरा उपयोग अंदर चले जा रहा है, मैं ध्यान करूँगा। लेकिन अचानक क्या
हुआ नहीं मालूम। और बाहर से उपयोग रहा नहीं,
बाहर लक्ष रहा नहीं।
और अपने आप इच्छा हो गई,
चलो इस time क्यों waste करूँ, चलो बैठूँ ना। बैठते ही काम शुरू हो गया।
इसको क्या बोलते हैं? ये अचानक, no pre-planning.
ध्यान करने की कोई pre-planning नहीं। अपने आप इसको
बोलते हैं सवज। ये सब... होते है सहज.
ए सब साधना करने वाले को ए सब अनुभव में आता है. उसके साधना नहीं किये यहां तक
उसको problem है. अब ज्ञान की clarity की बात करना. क्षणे क्षणे अबंध
स्वरूप प्रगट थतुं जाय छे.
जब एसा होता है तब वर्तमान में पुण्यभाव थाय
अने एनुं अनुकूळ फळ मने मळे एवी वांछा
आवा आत्मज्ञानीने क्यारे पण होती? होती। इसीलिए जब आप मुझे बोलते
हो कि सर सोनगढ़ आओ।
और नहीं आते हो तो मेरे पाप का उदय है ऐसा बोलते हो।
और पाप का उदय मिटाने के लिए तीव्र भावना करो ताकि पुण्य की उदय हो जाए।
पाप का उदय पलट जाए मुझे ऐसा भिखारी बनना पसंद नहीं। ये बात कह दी।
सहज में पुण्य का उदय होगा और सोनगढ़ आना होगा और
गुरु के दर्शन मिलने वाले होंगे तो okay।
तो मैं रोकूंगा नहीं। लेकिन सामने से चला करके।
मुझे गुरु का सानिध्य चाहिए ना मुझे उनके दर्शन चाहिए।
और ये सब बेकार लोग हैं इनके साथ में काहे को फंसा हूँ।
मुझे ऐसे लोगों के साथ नहीं रहना है भाव जाना है। ये बात मेरे पास नहीं हो।
मैं पाप के उड़े से बचना नहीं चाहता।
पुण्य के उड़े को मैं लाना नहीं चाहता। मैं जहाँ हूँ वहाँ।
बार में अंश मात्र भी मैं changes करना नहीं चाहता। क्यों?
मुझे परमात्मा मिल गया है। मारो धन्य थयो आज अवतार के,
मिल्या
मने परमात्मा। मुझे भिखारी बनना नहीं आता है क्योंकि मैं परमात्मा
हूँ। परमात्मा था तो परमात्मा
रहूँ। हो गई बात? अब कहाँ change करना है? अब तो जो भी नाटक देखने...
नाटक देखने। बाद में तो film आती है पाप और पुण्य के उड़े।
पल पल में फसल बनते रहते हैं
लेकिन भिक्षा नहीं कमाना। पुण्य के फल की वांछा ज्ञानी को नहीं होती।
अभी 10-15 minute है देखेंगे और आगे।
बहुत बढ़िया actor। अपने
statement और। कीचड़ में घसने पर भले
गद्दी पर था। में घसने पर बड़े गद्दी पंखा जाता
है। समझा जंगल में कहीं दलदल में फंस गए।
अब अपने को मालूम नहीं है कितनी गहराई अंदर खटकी। पैर फिसलते ही ऐसा
थोड़ा प्रयत्न करते ही और अंदर चला जाता है। अब क्या लगता है?
अब तो लगता है कुछ हाथ पैर मारो, हाथ पैर मारोगे तो भी ना हो जाए, ऐसा कहीं ना हो जाए।
थोड़ा पैर और अंदर गया, ऐसा पूरा चले जाए,
उंगली भी चले जाए अंदर। क्या होगा? ये सब जाएगा तो... क्या होगा ये सब जाएगा तो?
दलदल में पूरा अंदर गया तो क्या होता है? खत्म हो गया मामला।
डर लग जाता है। कीचड़ में घसने पर
भय वृद्धि पाता है। थोड़ा हाथ पैर मारा और ज्यादा खड्डे में गए।
पहले ये पहले यहाँ तक था समझो।
थोड़ा बचने की कोशिश की तो यहाँ तक घुस गए अंदर। अब क्या होगा? भयभीत हो
जाता है। भयवान हो जाता है।
भय वृद्धि पाता है। परंतु इसका opposite है।
चैतन्य में घसने पर, इसमें घुसने पर क्या होता है? निर्वयता।
निर्वयता वृद्धि पाती है। देखिए
डर निकल जाता है। self confidence आ जाता है। नहीं नहीं मुझे
मोक्ष नहीं चाहिए। मेरा क्या होगा मुझे चिंता नहीं हो रही मुझे
सब कुछ मिल गया है। मुझे
परमात्मा मिल गया मुझे
अब कुछ मेरा बाल भी बांका नहीं। जितना... जितना अंदर जाते हो ना,
इतना double confidence आ जाता है।
जितनी बार जाते हो ना, उतना double confidence आ जाता
है। दुनिया कुछ भी कहे, मुझे परवाह नहीं है किसी से। मेरा confidence है मेरे
पास। अब मैं वापस जाने वाला,
मैदान में आ गया हूँ। अब मारूँ या मरूँ नहीं, मारूँ ही मारूँ। क्या है?
पहले क्या था, जब गया था interview के लिए तो कहा क्या था?
मारूँ या मरूँ, या फिर मैं मारूँगा या फिर मैं मर जाऊँगा। मैं मरूँगा या फिर मैं मर
जाऊँगा। लेकिन अंदर जाने के बाद क्या हुआ? कौन सा आया power?
मरने का तो सवाल ही नहीं है मैं आज अमर कैसे मरूँगा? अब मरेगा कौन?
जितने पूर्व में कर्म भले बांधे हैं अनंत भले हैं वो।
मैं उनको सबको खत्म कर दूँगा। एक भी जिंदा नहीं बचेगा। सबसे
पहले दर्शकों को मार दिया है।
के अब चूहे हैं बहुत सारे।
अनंत भुवन के चक्कर में। लेकिन एक... लेकिन एक को भी जिंदा नहीं रखूँगा।
अब मारूँ या मारूँ नहीं।
अब एक ही sentence रहा है क्या?
मारूँ मारूँ। तो क्या होता है डर निकल गया कि कहीं ऐसा ना हो कि सब मिलकर के
मेरे को घेरा डाल करके चक्रव्यूह में फँसा देवे।
वापिस मुझे संसारी बना देवे विचार करके। Impossible है बना ही नहीं सकते।
मेरा प्रभु मेरे साथ है भले ही मैं अकेला हूँ। लेकिन अनंत कर्मों के... अनंत कर्मों के
रजकणों के ऊपर मैं भारी पड़ूँ।
हाँ इतना ज़रूर है देर है मेरे परमात्मा होने में अंधेर नहीं है।
क्या हो सकता है कि भई एक भाव में ना हो एक भाव तक ना बनो
दो चार भाव बने maximum 15 भाव बने पक्का जाने में। लेकिन जीत किसकी है?
हो सकता है जीत हो या हार हो लेकिन नहीं नहीं अब हार का तो question ही नहीं है।
क्या? No question of हार। अब तो जीत। नो भाव. अब तो जीत ही जीत दी. केवल ज्ञाननो
धंधो मने अहियांथी देखाय छे. शुं?
सौभासभाई केता ता मने कथारी. अंतिम समये
आया ता पंडने भेजाता अंबालालभाई को.
के जाओ भईया आप उनकी सेवा में रहो. केटना दिन रहेंगे हो ज्योतिष ज्ञान तो जानते थे.
दिन तो आगे थे सौभासभाई कब जावे क्यां मालुम कब देखेंगे.
अंबालालभाई को भेजाता. को दे। कमल भाई उनको
आत्मसिद्धि में। बोलने लगे, जागृति के। ए चुप बैठ, क्या बोले?
सुबह में। इतने आत्मसिद्धि
में, हम power में की पढ़ रहा हूँ, आपको जरा जागृति आना है। जागृति, क्या बोलते हो?
चुप बैठ, बंद कर बोरी तेरी। भई काहे के अर्थ है, आपको तो बहुत पसंद है आत्मसिद्धि।
power में लिखी है। मुझे disturb मत करो, मुझे केवल ज्ञान की धजा दिख रही है।
क्या?
चुप बैठ। चुप करा दिया। power
क्या है? क्या power है? ये केवल ज्ञान की धजा दिखती है, चौथे गुणस्थान में है अभी।
मरने की घड़ी आई है, मरण पथारी पे
है। same ऐसा किस्सा हमारे
इधर हुआ। ऑटिज्म का last day। Hospital का last day। 6 बजे के
बाद फिर तबीयत बिगड़ी। और कोई chances नहीं थे। कि यहाँ से खून
चढ़ाया था एक bottle 3 घंटे में लगती थी।
लेकिन खून इतना बह रहा था। कि यहाँ भी और यहाँ भी। 3 bottle साथ में चढ़ाने को।
और इतना fast खून बहता था बाहर।
कि एक bottle को 3 घंटा लगता था इसकी जगह पे 3 bottle को 1 घंटा लगता था
खाली होने में। इतना fast body
लेती थी। भागम दोड़ी करके 20-25 bottle तो हमने cover कर लिया।
कि सुबह तक रहे जिंदा तो। लव पड़ेगी तो 20-25 bottle। जिंदा
बचने का तो कोई chance नहीं था लेकिन हम ये चाहते थे कि जितना ज्यादा fight करें ना
जागरूक अवस्था में।
जितना लंबा समय खींचे ना। उतनी उनकी साधना अंदर की अच्छी हो।
साधना कैसे जिंदा रखना है इसीलिए
bottle चढ़ाने का था बाकी बचने का तो
कोई chance ही नहीं था। खून की bottle तो 20-25 मंगाता रहता। एक घंटे
में 3 चाहिए तो रात भर निकालना है तो।
सुबह तक भी 20-25 bottle तो चाहिए ही चाहिए सब मंगा लिया।
और। मालूम तो पूरा पहले
से 4 दिन पहले से दवा बंद की थी मालूम तो पड़ ही गया था। The end
है। दो end है। 6 बजे के बाद जो तबीयत बिगड़ करके जो 8 बजे ना तो मैं गया था।
तो तुम फिकर मत करो
सब तुम पहले जाओ तैयारी करके रखना हम भी आ रहे हैं सब 20 पटे साल पीछे।
कोई 10 साल नहीं कोई 20 साल। सब साथ में ही साधना करेंगे चिंता मत करो।
ऐसा बोला। और तुम मैं मैं रमा नहीं हूँ मैं आत्मा हूँ। ऐसा बोला।
कि मुझे please आप कुछ भी मत बोलो मैं मेरे आत्मा में जाना चाहती
हूँ। मुझे disturb... मुझे disturb होता है अभी आप कुछ
भी मत
बोलना मेरे
से। ये last
word थे उसके बाद बोले नहीं अंदर।
ऐसी 8:00 बजे के बाद 9:30 बजे first attack आया coma का। डेढ़ घंटे
तक अंदर ही अंदर ना बात ना चीज ना होश में पूरे बोले। 9:30 बजे attack आया
तब first stage coma का आता है। First stage... First time में क्या
है कुछ थोड़ा बहुत अपना एहसास करा तो
मालूम पड़ता है।
फिर रात को 10:30 10:45 बजे दूसरा attack आया तब फिर अपना एहसास करा तो
मालूम नहीं पड़ पाता था।
इसके बाद attack आया। तो chances
पूरे 10 minute का लेकिन इसके बाद भी आधे घंटे के बाद दूसरा attack आया।
वो बोला 5 minute भी नहीं इसके बाद भी निकाला वो
ने time। Date change हो गई। ये सब। ये
सब नज़ारा आँखों के सामने सबने देखा
है। ICU में हम लोग कितने 10-15 जने थे
ऊपर खड़े हुए। आज्ञा मानने वाले को भी लेकिन ये
ऐसे प्रसंग में सबको जाने दिया। सब लोगों ने आँखों से देखा
आँखों से। ऐसा होता है केवल ज्ञान का झंडा दिखता है
इतना power होता है। ये बात इस पर से निकली।
कि कीचड़ में घसने पर तो भय वृद्धि होता है। लेकिन चैतन्य में घसने पर
निर्भयता वृद्धि पाती जाती है। मैं चैतन्य चैतन्य में ही चलता हूँ
और खोखा जड़ जड़ में चलता है। विभाव विभाव में है।
मुझ नित्य में मेरी पर्याय का और वेदन का भी प्रवेश...
देखो उपयोग कहाँ रखता है? ज्ञानी पुरुष का
उपयोग कहाँ रहता है? जब दृष्टि
अंदर रहती है तो कहाँ रहता है? एक कोखे पे तो नहीं... कहा है। ये
कोके पे तो नहीं रहती।
जड़ जड़ में मैं मैं। कोका मरो
बोली अंदर में जो विकल्प आते हैं मन में।
वो विकल्प विकल्प में और मैं मेरे जानने वाला अलग। अरे
जो पर्याय होती है शांति की उत्पन्न वेदन की भर्ती आती है।
कि वेदन भी मैं नहीं हूँ मेरे से बाहर boundary के बाहर वेदन वेदन में और मैं।
वो चेतने पे दृष्टि रखने से constant। कानून की भर्ती करते जाते हैं।
मुझ नित्य में अनित्य मेरी पर्याय का प्रवेश भी नहीं हुआ।
मैं नित्य पर्याय मेरी पर्याय अनित्य।
मैं सत्य मेरा
मेरी पर्याय मेरी आ गई तो मेरा मेरी असत्य। मैं नित्य।
मुझ नित्य में मेरी पर्याय का भी प्रवेश नहीं तो
अन्य की बात... का भी प्रवेश नहीं तो अन्य की बात क्या? अरे परिणाम परिणमता है।
और उसी समय same moment मैं अपरिणामी हूँ।
ये ये अनुभव में से निकली हुई बातें हैं। अनुभव करते करते लिखी।
अनुभव करने के बाद फौरन पत्र लिखा हो। कि परिणाम परिणमता है,
परिणाम परिणमन तो रुकने वाला कहाँ है? बढ़ती नहीं तो घट, घट नहीं तो...
बढ़ती नहीं तो ओठ, ओठ नहीं तो... बढ़ती, वो तो होने वाला है। चढ़ना
उतरना तो पर्याय का स्वभाव है,
नहीं तो होने वाला है। परिणाम परिणमते हैं, लेकिन उसी समय...
मैं और परिणाम नहीं हूँ। बढ़ती हो या ओठ हो, मैं तो समुंदर हूँ।
क्या? बढ़ती और ओठ तो अवस्था है,
और मैं अवस्था से पार त्रिकाली द्रव्य हूँ, शाश्वत हूँ।
परिणाम... परिणाम परिणमता है उसी समय में अपरिणम्य।
अरे भगवान कारण परमात्मा अपने को बोलते हैं महिमा के वचन।
अरे भगवान कारण परमात्मा
तेरे दर्शन होते ही विभाव की पीठ दिखने लगी है।
मालूम पड़ता है राग द्वेष काम क्रोध मोह... द्वेष, काम, क्रोध, मोह भागने लगे हैं।
सामने नहीं आना चाहते, सामने आए तो जल जाते हैं। छुपने लग गए हैं, भाग गए काये सब।
तेरे दर्शन मात्र कृष्ण भगवान रथ में बैठे
हैं। रथ चला रहे हैं और दूध धनाधन ठोक के जा रहा है। मारुति कुमार सा।
काये पर वो सामने आता है भाई? कोई आता है सामने, सामने आने
को? तो मौत निश्चित है समझ। सामने आया। क्या हुआ? सामने आया। तो क्या होता है?
कि परमात्मा का रथ। चारा है और इधर धरती की एक तार लगी है अंदर में।
तीर के ऊपर तीर आ जाते हैं। सामने बेचारे कहाँ से आएँगे? आए ज़्यादा।
ये अकेला है वो कितने हैं? बहुत सारे हैं। काम, क्रोध, मद, मोह,
माया, इतना। 25 प्रकार के कसाए हैं।
इसमें अनंत अनुबंधी के 4 हैं बाकी सब बाकी हैं। विचार है बाकी सब बाकी
है। आराम बराबर कोई सामने आएगा तो
सब भागने लगे छुपने लगे कि मेरे सामने आ जाएगा मर जाएगा। कचर निकल जाएगा पूरा। क्या?
तो तेरे दर्शन होते ही विभाव की पीठ टिकने लगती है।
वो सामना करता ही नहीं है भाग जाते हैं छुप जाते हैं। तेरा यथार्थ बाण हुए बिना।
भूतकाल किया पूर्व में।
परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का इतना तीव्र बंध। परिणामों का इतना तीव्र बंध कर चुका था।
तेरा तो मुझे पता नहीं था और मैं परिणाम के ऊपर दृष्टि थी।
और फिर ये चाहिए ना वो
चाहिए ना ऐसा नहीं ना वैसा नहीं ना इतना हमने परिणाम खराब कर लिए।
और इतने कर्म बांध लिए थे और इतने तीव्र बंध कर लिए थे। कि अब
इतने सारे वो जमा हो गए कर्मों के ऊपर।
कि उनकी अवधि खत्म होने के लिए अब उन सबको
एक साथ मारने के लिए जल्दी से। तेरा दस। तेरा दर्शन तो स्वाभाविक होना ही था।
कि तू नहीं मिलता तो इनको कैसे खत्म करूँगा? इतने पैदा हो गए थे।
कितने बंधन हो गए
अनंत काल में?
अब उसको खत्म करने के लिए अनंत काल लगे क्योंकि अनंत काल में बंधे गए कर्म
हैं। अगर एक-एक करके मैं निकालूँ
एक के बाद एक, कितना time लगे?